it's rare that a film comes along it
splits the movie community so much a
film that some laud as a masterpiece and
others say is actually the worst film
they've ever seen this year only God
forgives is that movie as I've done in
the past with Prometheus Drive and a
good day to die hard I'm going to delve
in depth into this film and give my
thoughts on its mini meetings and
underlying metaphors so sit back grab
some popcorn and let's get nerdy about
only God forgives but please keep in
mind two things one this review features
mini spoilers so please check out my
spoiler free review first if you don't
wish to know the details of the film and
two this is just my interpretation there
are a few factual thoughts about this
film out there you really can only make
up your own ideas so keep that in mind
as you watch this the movie opens with
just a taste of the incredible
cinematography that Larry Smith has to
offer its opening shots are so
beautifully crafted it pains me to know
that the Academy will likely not
consider this film for Best
Cinematography due to its lurid content
we learn quickly that Julianne played by
Ryan Gosling manages a Thai boxing club
and through a series of shots it becomes
clear that it's really just a front for
drugs we're introduced to Billy
Julian's brother who says time to meet
the devil before going out to feed his
lewd psychopathic urges take note of
where Gosling stands in this scene
staring at his brother with a look of
contempt the next few scenes are fairly
straightforward Billy attacks some women
and we learned that he eventually kills
one of them the cops call in a retired
officer named Chang to exact some form
of vengeance on the situation we also
get our first shot of Julianne staring
at his hands beneath a fighter statue
hands are a humongous thing in this
movie we'll talk more about that soon
upon making eye contact with Chang
Billy's expression reveals something
much greater than a human has entered
the room you can tell he knows Chang
isn't normal in fact most people in this
film look at Chang as if he's not normal
in some way so let's just get this out
of the way Chang is God I mean it's not
even my interpretation Nicolas Winding
Ruffin has flat-out said that in
interviews he even directed the actor
before shooting by whispering in his ear
you are God
this explains many things in the film
why he draws a sword from nowhere why
he's virtually untouchable and why he
exacts vengeful justice on sinners as
well as forgiveness Chang has the
murdered girl's father brought in and
rather than comforting or consoling him
he asks him how he could let his
daughter be a prostitute how could he
let this happen he asks he then gives
the father a choice do what you want he
says he gives the father free will to
choose what to do with his daughter's
killer
the father kills Billy after seeing the
remains of the father's rampage Chang
brings the father outside and asks him
to explain himself the father begs for
forgiveness Chang wants to know what he
is sorry for it's clear that Chang is
trying to explain to the father that his
real sin was letting his daughters work
as prostitutes he pulls out a sword
seemingly from nowhere and cuts off the
father's arm saying that this is so
you'll never forget them in reference to
his three living daughters next we meet
my and we get a rather interesting scene
where she touches herself as Julianne
remains tied up while also entering a
sort of dreamlike vision many have
speculated that Julianne seeming
inability to have normal sexual
encounters with women stems from an
awkward and possibly forced incest with
his mother we'll talk more about that
later as my starts to do the deed
Julianne doesn't even look like he's
enjoying it he actually looks remorseful
about the whole ordeal then we cross
dissolve into a shot of Julianne panning
in on him and we enter an interesting
vision he seems to be having we see a
shot of an arm in the darkness suddenly
Julianne is no longer tied up he begins
roaming the halls approaching a dark
door reaching into it Chang appears in
the darkness chopping off Julian's arm
much like he did to the father's
my finishes what she was doing
Chang then appears out of the darkness
and Julian is back in his chair
appearing as if he has just had a
profound revelation their session is
interrupted when Julian's business
associate and forms him that his
brother's been killed
Julian's reaction isn't exactly filled
with tears and sorrow in the next scene
we get the first of many karaoke songs
sung by Chang this is probably my least
favorite aspect of the film it's
definitely my least favorite aspect
Nikolas winning repin has stated that
the Thai people view this activity as
almost a religious practice
thus he felt the inclusion of it in the
film was important take note that Chang
tends to sing whenever he's just exact
adventures on someone next we meet
Julian's mother crystal this scene
quickly makes clear that you don't want
to be on the bad side of this woman now
many have speculated that crystal
represents the devil I don't know if I
buy into this I think it's just easy to
assume when a movie features a character
that represents God that logically there
would be a devil as well it's true that
she is always the evil voice in Julian's
ear telling him what to do and win
belittling him insulting him but to say
that she flat-out represents the devil I
think is taking a bit of a leap who
knows I could be wrong as I said all
this is just my interpretation
nothing factual here in the next scene
we see that Julian and his associates
have tracked down the father who killed
Billie he's now missing an arm and he
begins to tell his story to Julian who
eventually shows him mercy letting him
go when the father speaks the audio
fades out we see Julian's face as if
he's acknowledging something profound
when the father points to his arm Julian
seems to understand something
it's like he's made a tiny connection in
his head possibly relating to the
dreamlike vision he had earlier we even
get a shot of Chang's sword in the
darkness again it's almost like Julian
is starting to understand the
significance of what took place being
forgiven of one's sins but being
burdened by a constant reminder of them
Raffin makes the choice to have
significant moments told mostly through
visuals and an incredible score by cliff
Martinez we then get a look at Chang's
home
it's peaceful he takes care of his
daughter he seems to be a good man he
stares at his window watching over the
surroundings we didn't see Julian's
hands again as he watches them in the
sink but upon looking down at them he
suddenly has blood all over his hands
now we get another dreamlike vision in
which Gosling roams the halls inter
spliced with shots of Chang he
approaches the dark door again this time
fearful he eventually backs away in
dread this is when Julian meets up with
his mother is incredibly obvious
throughout this scene that Julian's
relationship with her is just not normal
she's upset that Julian didn't kill the
man who killed her son she doesn't seem
to care that Billie raped and killed a
little girl she's pretty much the worst
mother you could have the scene ends
with a very telling shot of crystal
caressing Julian's arm that doesn't look
like the normal type of motherly love if
you ask me I mean she basically fondles
his ass as soon as she sees him this is
just one of the reasons that Julian is
so tormented the other is explained
later she says she'll take care of the
blankety-blank blank man who killed her
son that it's just too much for Julian
to handle Julian was jealous of his
brother his mother clearly loved Billie
more than Julian Plus as we'll learn
later Julian had been involved with a
pretty messy family situation that could
have easily screwed him and his brother
up even more we'll talk more about that
soon it's quickly summed up that crystal
hire someone to kill the father who
killed her son
but she learns of Chang's involvement as
well and sets out to kill him too now
Julian is back at the club julian is
wearing a black shirt as he watches my
more shots of his hands I believe now
that he imagines himself approaching my
do to his shirt color changing to white
in his fantasy he begins to get a little
nasty with my who is now wearing a
different dress as well putting his
hands towards her I believe he yearns to
have a normal relationship with a woman
but due to his strange upbringing with
his mother he can't he imagines things
fantasizes watches he imagines my
holding his hands comforting him
don't worry I'll explain the hands thing
soon in the middle of his fantasy an
image of his mother is inserted his eyes
open I believe he can't get over
occurrences that happened with his
mother
this enrages him and causes him to lead
an abnormal life to laughing men snap
him out of his trance at least I think
that's what happens and Julian doesn't
like this he attacks them both out of
rage dragging one of them across the
floor now this scene looks like it's
leading to something but it abruptly
ends which bothered me
perhaps this was something he imagined
as well but I don't think so we're left
wondering what happens next the cops
visit Julian questioning him about the
death of the girl's father Julian sees
Chang now and this time it doesn't seem
to be a prophetic vision you can tell
Julian is intimidated by him Chang says
Julian isn't the one they're looking for
Julian then decides to follow Chang
I mean hey if you were seeing visions of
someone who eventually showed up you'd
follow him too wouldn't you but the
godlike Chiang disappears next we get a
montage showing Chang practicing with
his sword his instrument of justice and
crystal planning his eventual death
Julian then approaches my and asks her
to pretend to be his girlfriend so she
can meet his mother
I am convinced that Julian wants to show
his mother that he has a girl in his
life besides her and the following scene
at dinner tells us why his mother
insults virtually everything about him
right down to the size of his hoo-ha
when compared to his brother's
furthering my belief that crystal had an
abnormal sexual relationship with her
sons in the next scene Julian lashes out
against Mai when she mentions his mother
he screams at her in one of the only
true outbursts he has in the film it's
clear that any mention of his mother at
this point is not something he wants to
hear he almost immediately regrets this
outburst it's very apparent that his
childhood with his mother has ruined his
life next we see the planned assault on
Chang and the subsequent carrying out of
that plan in which the untouchable Chang
chases down the one killer who gets away
apprehending him the shots leading up to
this show that Chang expected that
something was
coming throughout this scene everyone
dies except Chang and his guardian
angels the other cops Chang even knows
exactly where the man will be circling
around finding him with ease he's led to
the man who planned the attack and upon
seeing that the man is willing to accept
his fate but only wishes his boy be
protected spares him he once again draws
his sword seemingly from nowhere and
exacts justice on the remaining killer
he spares the man and his child now once
again at a karaoke bar
Chang confronts the other man involved
and in a scene I personally felt went
too far blinds the man and stabs his
ears because he refuses to see or listen
he says he never appears to be enjoying
this only dealing justice it was really
Ruffin that I felt was enjoying the
violence a little too much fetishizing
it which he's publicly admitted to Chang
having once again dealt justice goes to
sing some karaoke again clearly a
religious experience for him I get it
it just got tedious after a while for me
this time however Julien is at the bar
apparently having tracked down Chang it
seems to me that Chang is staring at
Julien while he sings for reasons I'm
unsure of Julien seems extremely
affected by this when Julian wants to
challenge Chang one of his cops asks him
do you know who he is
the way he says it it's like Julien and
everyone acknowledges that Chang is more
than human that Julien literally wants
to fight God which Nicolas Winding
reppin has said was a huge inspiration
to him while he wrote this movie the
idea of a man who wanted to fight God
so I'm actually under the impression
that these people acknowledge who Chang
actually is now we get the big fight
scene in which Julien lands not one
single punch
not even one Chang is completely
untouchable in every way during this
fight scene were shown the statue that
Julien stood before earlier clenching
his fists it's clear that Julien wants
to be able to fight as he sort of
imitated the stance of
that statue but he's just not up to par
with someone like say God in the next
scene crystal now stands before a broken
julienne in the same place Julian stared
at his brother earlier she says when she
was pregnant with Julian she felt that
it was an odd pregnancy as if Julian
wanted her to terminate she also begs
him to protect her from Chang she
promises that she can be a good mother
dame again and mentioned something about
Julian's father she says I know after
your father I'd never ask you again
Julian is a little hopeful now he
clearly yearns for the approval of his
mother this drives Julian to kill the
guard at Chang's house and break inside
with his associate who seems to think
everyone must die including the child
Julian doesn't like this meanwhile Chang
and his guardian angels pay a visit to
Crystal where we learned the most
important piece of Julian's past he
killed his own father with his bare
hands she says this makes a lot more of
the movie clearer to me I believe when
Julian stares at his hands as he does so
often and gives his hands to my in a
fantasy so that she can rub them and
comfort him he feels a strong sense of
regret for what he did to his father add
that to his terrible upbringing with his
mother and you've got one broken man I
feel that he yearns for forgiveness for
his sins which is why he keeps having
strange prophetic visions of Chang
cutting his arms off and his hands in
the sink that have blood on them so to
speak she talks more about her special
relationship with Billie and how Julian
was so jealous essentially I believe
that Julian's youth led him to be this
way killing his own father the hint of
incest and having no real understanding
of a normal sexual relationship would
just make about anyone go a little nuts
but as seen in the next scene where
Julian saves the little girl from death
it's clear he still has a moral Center
and longs for forgiveness for his sins
the things his mother is saying to the
cops makes it clear she really doesn't
want a life with her son anymore I mean
hell she just told the cops her son's a
murderer this leads me to believe that
it is possible that she stands for the
devil
but I'm not sure on that one she's
manipulative evil and the voice in
Julian's ear constantly encouraging him
to do wrong but like I said it's not
entirely sure to me this is when Chang
decides to enter the room once it's
clear how horrible of a mother crystal
really is it's almost like he was
listening willing to give her one last
chance but he knows she isn't who she
says she is he removes his magical sword
and kills her exacting justice once
again Julian then takes one of Chang
swords and finds his dead mother in her
room leading to one of the most
confusing scenes in the movie he stabs
the body with the sword and reaches
inside feeling around the first time I
saw this I really didn't like or
understand this scene having seen the
film three times now I honestly am still
confused by it there are multiple
theories floating around out there
according to the IMDB trivia page under
the spoiler section quote it was Ryan
Gosling's idea to open the stomach of
Julian's dead mother
he had it after a director Nicolas
Winding ref and asked him if he'd rather
smile or cry after Julian's mom's death
he replied that he'd opened her uterus
to see what's inside
end quote if that really is the reason
then indeed Julian is a very damaged boy
some have speculated that this was a
metaphor for crawling back into the womb
some have thought it had something to do
with wanting to transfer his guilt back
to his mother as his hands are metaphor
for guilt or regrets in most people's
eyes or he's just pretty messed up
either way I'm not sure this scene was
necessary he seems to fantasize again
showing up in the bar seeing my and
seeing Chang there once again looking
oddly warm and kind of inviting
immediately we see Julian raising his
hands in a completely different location
putting his guilt and regret out in
front of Chang finally we get the full
arc of the vision Julian had again
seeing the shot of Chang raising his
sword in the darkness
Chang accepts this sacrifice and
forgives him by removing Julian's arms
thus the title on
God forgives so in a way this is
actually a happy ending for Julian he's
accepted his punishment and moved on
from his past he can now try to lead a
better life at least this is my
interpretation of the film it ends with
Chang again singing karaoke having just
exacted justice now apparently the
original script featured another scene
of an armless Julien being fed pudding
by my I really wish this scene remained
in the film it would have helped
solidify that Julian was learning to
have a normal relationship with a woman
moving on from his past life I think it
would have justified more of the
violence in the eyes of the film as many
critics I'll be honest
watching the film a few more times did
heighten my appreciation for it much
more the karaoke still annoys me I still
think the torture scene goes too far
and I'm still unsure about the scene
where Julian cuts open his mother but I
think in time away from the hype this
film will gain more respect it's not
your typical film at all and many people
were disappointed by its odd structure
but I truly have never seen a film like
it which is a huge compliment when
reffing garnered much attention with
Drive everyone started watching him the
critics would be harsher the audience
more judgmental but having made films
like Valhalla Rising previously in which
the main hero literally didn't speak one
single word Raffin has certainly treaded
ground like only God forgives before
with time this movie will find its
audience I hope you liked my
interpretation of only God forgives and
that it helps shine some light on the
film for those who had a tough time
understanding it as always guys thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes